we welcome now the head basketball coach
of those oregon state beavers
fellow montanan mr wayne tinkle wayne
how are you doing coach oh doing great
really good to be with you but hey we
play
loyola chicago in in the sweet 16. dad
throw that in there oh gosh you're but
no i like the way you think
i thought why did i think that we we
would we would play syracuse
in the elite yes yes no this is much
this makes it a much more
interesting conversation loyola chicago
very underseated wouldn't you say
as an eight seed as were you guys but i
want to know a little bit more
about this run because i i had you on my
radio show earlier in the year kind of
after that
that that beat down um you guys had
in oregon state and how you had a come
to
kind of jesus moment with your team and
the difference
that that made for the rest of the
season and what you guys ultimately
became
talk about that and what the season was
like
yeah i mean it was tough even earlier in
the year we lose to portland
uh at home in overtime i think i think
they
they only won maybe six or seven games
um
what was was a tough loss you know we
get into conference play right after
christmas
we we have to have a pause for kovid
couple guys test positive
and so we had an eight day pause and
then we had
two practices to prepare for arizona
and we were their only game of the week
because oregon was in a pause so we got
both
arizona and arizona state where we were
their only game of the week
and they yeah they gave us a woodshed
job and uh we had a couple guys hurt in
that game too but
we had a meeting the next day the staff
seven straight hours we ordered in some
lunch
and we just did a scrub of the whole
deal and we came up with this
that our guys were trying to win a
national championship
in december and january and we were
missing a lot of steps
so we said let's let's just give them
three things to focus on
that that we'll be able to judge from
those whether it was a success or not
and it was executing our stuff pretty
generic i know
playing harder than our opponent and
enjoying playing with each other that
was missing you know we got a lot of
young guys we've only got a couple of
experienced guys
so we sold that to the team so guys if
you focus on just those
things it'll be a successful game
if you achieve that and then it'll lead
to wins we don't know what when we can't
promise you
but they bought into it we went went on
a three game uh win streak after that
um and and got the momentum going and
then one other turning point at cal
our last road weekend of the regular
season
um we we're you know big weekend playing
cal stanford
we had some guys kind of roll their eyes
when they were subbed out roll their
eyes when i got after them for taking
crappy shots
and and we just we lit them up we lit
them up in several timeouts we lit them
up
at halftime uh i mean the paint was
peeling in the locker room
and our guys responded and and we we got
a tough win there
and then went to stanford and they they
were a little beat up with injuries but
a big win there
and that's when everything kind of fell
into place and the guys were like
okay now we've had all this experience
we understand what it's all about we got
to play hard every day
play together you know and stay focused
and now we're now we're in the sweet 16
baby so i couldn't be
more proud of the group uh we're talking
the head coach of
the oregon state university beavers
men's basketball coach
wayne tinkle um
the loss to oregon to finish the season
heading into the tournament
uh in vegas and then the lackluster kind
of first half what
what flipped the switch there in vegas
that took you on this run
that we're at right now you know i think
it was more more of the same
like they like the guys they didn't we
didn't follow the scouting report
in the game at home against oregon we we
let them
shoot lights out they got it going on us
um
you know they made 11 more threes than
us
and and what we told the guys shoot we
should have lost by 25
but you guys did a few good things to
you know keep it you know somewhat close
i think we lost by 11.
and then we kind of carried that into
the first game against
ucla we just reverted back to
individual play not not the same
intensity on the defensive end
and in a time out at towards the end of
the first half we said no
no no no we didn't quite say it like
that
um but we're not going back to the past
all right let's
remember what what has you know brought
success and get back on page
and then at halftime you know some
adjustments and then the guys came out
and totally turned that game around i
think we were down as much as 16. came
back and and won that one in overtime
and i thought that was kind of that
final injection of
uh enthusiasm and confidence that we
needed
uh you know to to push forward and you
know we we put it on oregon pretty good
in the in the semifinals and then
uh you know got up against colorado they
made a late run but we closed it out
and uh you know then our guys have
really been dialed here i mean
you said it we handled tennessee and
then uh got
got up uh you know after oklahoma state
got up 9-4
we we jumped them and got a nice lead
and you know their their athletic is all
get out and
and turned us over a bunch to get back
in but then we closed the door on them
late too so
the guys are riding quite a wave yeah
they are it's been
it's been fun to watch it's been fun to
watch the pac 12 have success and i want
maybe you to comment a little bit about
the undervalued pac-12 conference
because
guess what 25 percent of this week 16
everybody
25 are pac-12 teams oregon oregon state
usc and ucla uh unfortunately oregon and
usc are going to be
uh going up against each other to get
into the elite eight but just talk about
the conference in general and how
competitive it was this year and the
fact that you had to play
mostly conference opponents in every
conference this year we really didn't
probably know the the real value of each
and every conference no for sure yeah we
didn't have those cross-conference
pre-season games um but you know i i
said
and people were kind of amazed at how we
performed against you know tennessee and
oklahoma state but
you know my comment was our conference
prepared us for that you know
we when we got teams that can defend and
can score
uh you know i think it's like seven out
of the last 10 years we've
had more players in the nba draft than
any other conference
uh you know we've we've got some guys
that can play you know there's great
coaches in the league
you know and it just you look at some of
the stats now i think
this is only the second time that a
conference has had two teams that were
double-digit seeds going into the ncaa
tournament make the sweet 16.
um and i think auburn and kentucky were
the other
was the other time and so you know ucla
and ourselves
have done that you look at we're nine
and one uh to this point
you know in the in the tournament that's
one of the top five
best starts um you know for teams that
have at least five teams in the
tournament so
uh we've got some guys that can play
there's there's there's great coaches
i just think you know that bias most of
the east coast is asleep when we're
playing our games and it's unfortunate
but uh hopefully this will be a little
bit of a wake-up call for the rest of
the country
all righty um i i you know i was gonna
wait this to maybe at the end of it but
uh we're speaking with wayne tinkle head
basketball coach
uh men's basketball coach at oregon
state university but the reason why
i i talked about syracuse is because i
already have you beating loyal chicago i
know you can't look that way but i'm
just
i'm letting you know that's that's
that's where i live yeah i would love
i've been i've been pumping i said i
want a all pac-12
national championship i want oregon ucla
usc versus the oregon state beavers i
think that would be
perfect not only for me but i especially
think bill walton
would ultimately retire and just go to
heaven
uh if that were to be the case so i
think you're right there
i think you're right um little known
fact right uh wayne tinkle
uh played at the university of montana
coached at the university of montana
and was around kind of at the end of my
high school career but mostly during my
brother's
i've asked him i asked him this question
before but and it's it's
it's illuminating what was the do you
remember the scouting report on me
coming out of high school
as a basketball player yes yep
guy that was was tough on the glass had
pretty good touch
could stretch it out a little bit maybe
not quite to the three-point line
um but uh very very very high skill set
and competitive i remember that not good
not great on defense though i think
not great on defense so i think was
probably the other one you notice i only
mentioned
the offense yes but the one that that
that ended up
making waves was my little brother he
would go on and go down and play for
coach fisher
at san diego state and uh he didn't end
up playing his entire career there but
he ended up actually being the the
basketball player in the family and
and that was the guy that was the guy
you you remember telling me that
maybe we maybe we didn't take a strong
look at that younger leaf kid
yeah no exactly and then and i can't
take the blame i don't think
you know i was the head coach at the
time and i'm trying to push the head
coach to recruit
recruit him i i told you i remember
seeing him playing the three-on-three
uh tournament up in great falls at the
fairgrounds yeah and said man we got we
got to get on this kid but
uh you you know it's you like to see
those
those stories of guys from you know
states like montana that
you know maybe they don't get the
recognition on the national scene
recruiting wise but then
you know get out and go to go to another
program outside of the state and have a
great career so
that's good stuff well it's been it's
been a pleasure
not only covering you this year um but
seeing
seeing the success um
tell us a little bit about some of the
some of the players that a lot of people
are getting a first
look at uh i hadn't heard too much about
silva and the way he's come around late
yeah
in the year uh alitishi um i know you're
hoping that he's he continues with his
high
quality of play but you know nba scouts
are going to start being like boy that
the length on that guy
um this is a team you could have back
next year that could be pretty darn
competitive
no we we really feel good about the run
we made and hey i'll go back
to last year we thought we were poised
for the same kind of a run
you know we we had won some late league
games we we won that
that tough game in the tournament
against utah with the buzzer beater
uh you know then then the thing was
pulled pulled from us but
you know we we struggled early this year
because of all the new pieces
and now you just mentioned two huge
parts now uh you know roman silva
uh you know spotty playing time last
year early this year he's gotten himself
into you know much better shape and
condition you know he battled through a
covid pause
and he you know work and the work that
coach rupp and the other coaches have
done with him we're starting to see
the fruits of their labor and you know
worry you worry it's an incredible
rebounder
he's so raw he's only been playing for
uh a handful of years
he needs some time that's what we keep
telling the scouts hey don't don't
don't go after him now he needs a little
more i'll call it marinating
but uh you know you look at those two
guys coming back
some of those other younger guys you
know gianni hunt jared lucas
tariq silver you know who hadn't played
much and actually tweaked his ankle last
week
two huge buckets for us in the second
half against oklahoma state because we
were
riddled in foul trouble ethan thompson
and jared lucas zach reichel and
alexis on the bench so we we thought
this
the depth on this team would would be
our strength
we just needed for it to get to where
they were confident could start
producing
consistently and and we feel we're there
so in in
the recruits we signed for next year
we're we're excited about what's going
on obviously and
um you know we still want to make this
continue this run
obviously this weekend but the future
looks bright for sure
we're talking to head coach of the
oregon state men's basketball team wayne
tinkle
right now in the sweet 16. we'll take on
loyola of chicago
a bit of a tournament darling as well
um how we'll get you out of here on this
uh unprecedented unconventional year
in a bubble in the indianapolis area
you know players not really being able
to spend time with one another
other than on the practice court um how
are you keeping them loose how is
everybody
staying motivated and and ready for the
next
next matchup yeah that's a great
question because that's the challenge i
mean
we've we we're on day 16 on the road
when when you
look at vegas in here both bubble
situations
um you know really the only free time we
have
there's a there's like a double a or
triple a baseball park across the street
and we get a an hour a day to to go walk
around
they have some footballs out there we
put up some pretty cool videos
guys playing football uh pickleball um
and then boom it's back to your room
so you know we're we're staying in touch
with them constantly making sure
they got everything they need you know
nowadays i mean they've all got
their ipads and they're jumping on
netflix and youtube and all that but
we certainly have to stay focused to you
know their mental state because this is
you know like you said it's
unprecedented and so we're constantly in
communication
this afternoon they get to sneak out to
uh topgolf
so i'll actually get out and away from
the hotel
which will be nice for them um the
coaching staff will be
we'll be in the team room uh breaking
down video but that'll be nice for them
and so we're just you know we're trying
to keep them loose on the practice court
but yet keeping them focused and intense
at the same time
just telling them to enjoy the ride why
change now you know we're not gonna
do anything different we said this going
into the championship game in vegas
don't do anything different because this
is you know means we can go to the ncaa
tournament just do what we do
said the same thing after the tennessee
game we'll say the same thing this
weekend
i sure hope so it's been a pleasure like
i said covering you guys this year
and watching it take place on the
national stage so
keep at it best of luck against loyola
chicago i already know where that's
going
uh wish your boys the best of luck and
uh we'll hopefully uh
maybe have you on the show next week
yeah
sounds good i appreciate you reaching
out it's always good talking to you
can't say enough how proud i am of our
guys man for all they've been through
and all their accomplishment it's a
pretty special group
thank you go beeps go beavs
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here